brady the title of this video is
tentacles akimbo
just because i've wanted to do something
that
sounds not mathematical but is
glassblower lucas clark comes over to my
house and says cliff i made something
and i can't understand it
and he shows me this it's two glass
tubes hooked as a ring
and you know you
treat his eyeglasses or you treat it as
two rings linked together like this he
says to me this is two rings connected i
say yeah it's mathematically a two-holed
taurus
he says okay he reaches over in his
bag and he pulls out
this
he says
isn't this the same thing and i say yeah
yeah you've just taken this stretched it
and so this is the same as this you know
it's still a two-holed
taurus with two holes in it topology
does not care about distance it doesn't
care about size
it's as if you make it out a stretchy
rubber
okay so he says what if i
i inflate the middle of this so i'm
going to just blow aaron inflate this i
say should make no difference in its
properties
so
it pulls out this
okay
from here
to here
it still has one two holes and it's
connected here uh it would be called a
two hole taurus or could also be called
a
handle body with two handles on it okay
no problem
so
i'm looking at thinking about him he
pulls out the next thing he says i can
take this
handle over here and go
and bring it over there
and i say yeah that should be no problem
so he does so he goes
over to there
so the next thing this glass blower does
is say
what happens
if i move this
connection here just
carry it around over to there
in this connection over to here they say
perfectly legal according to operations
and topology you can move this anywhere
you want as long as it's still connected
so he says i'm going to take that
connection and go
and this one go
like that
okay
so he does
so he moves those two ears from
being next to each other parallel to
so that they're connecting like this
[Music]
okay yeah
all legal so far everything's legal no
problem at all
he says
suppose i shrink this sphere part now
that's easy
i shrink it from that to this
oh what have you done now
so that
becomes
that
and this one
becomes this one here helps to have a
big nose and so this
sphere part becomes this wide part here
where'd that new hole come from there
what new hole this new hole here
where is it from
he starts asking me where is that from
and then he goes one step further and
fully shrinks that
into
this
ah
wait a second
he's telling me
that
this
can be transformed
into
this
following ordinary rules of topology i'm
looking at all this he's saying can you
explain it
and i'm saying
well
go back to this
this is a lot like a human being
it's like me
standing
with my arms
like this
there's a hole there and a hole there
this is
a kimbo
here i am a kimbo
and
this
is the same as me
with my fingers linked together like
this
yeah there's a hole here
there's a hole here and there's this
this space here that my head's waggling
around in is the same as this space here
right here's that space
is the same as
the space here okay yeah
my fingers are like this
and so i say somehow
this has been transformed to this
which is
the topologically the same as going from
a kimbo
two
interlinked fingers
so i'm sitting there i'm thinking i
ought to be able to go from here
to this
and that night i'm in bed trying to go
to you like this and my wife nudges me
and says cut it out cliff go to sleep
already and i keep going like this
waggling my fingers around it's not
working right and i'm saying what's
wrong with this and and and and
a couple days later visitor comes by
three visitors from denmark the people
are oftentimes coming over to my house
to check out topology and things
and i show this to them and these three
grad students i think from denmark came
through and i showed this to them and i
said i'll give you a klein bottle if you
could solve it they sit around thinking
about it talking about it and a couple
days later they show me the answer and
i'll show it to you now i'm going to
need a little bit of help i'm going to
need
a couple tentacles
can i go from
one arm a kimbo
to this
well i'll try it
the way i'll do it is i'll put a put my
finger here
and i claim that going like this is the
same
topologically as going like this
this
this tentacle is to just give me a
longer finger so i can go like this and
around like this
over to here
to my thumb
and then move my thumb along to this
got it thanks to the wonderful
miracle of of tentacles
i can show that i can go from here to
here
okay on my left hand i can do the same
thing
got it with two hands i can go from here
to here so this is a preserve you know
the number of holes one hole one hole
has been preserved
so what about
what about
with two hands going to this i'll start
with this
and
i'll start over here
and this hand here i'll go around over
to my nose there you go
there's my nose i'll now take this
finger over here
and bring it to my shoulder
like that
i'll now reach around
around this way
see the end of this
keeping it touching uh see i have to
keep the sky touching
i can move it
around
until it gets to my thumb
and get it like this
all right see how i've done that now i
could move my fingers together
i've got
get rid of that
i now have this shape right here i've
managed to bring my fingers around
to enclose this one finger
similarly having done that
i can take this finger
my left index finger
around
and go around this way
bring it like this
or you're there
like that
now is that cool or what
in other words
i can transform
from arms kimbo
into interlinked fingers
with the aid
of a couple tentacles
and by extrapolation i can do it if only
i had longer fingers if i had two longer
fingers i could do it entirely all of
which to me says topologically oh
there's cool things you can do with
tentacles
a kimbo but wait there's more freaky
there's more
good
okay first i'll show the lemma if you
start with your finger on your chest
you can extend to your thumb by falling
along your arm and this pointer finger
can go all the way down here up here and
connect right here with the sun to make
this
this is very useful watch
you have this we can extend this to just
fingers
just like the ball and get to this
then applying the lemon i just showed
you can go all the way up your arm
to get this
this can then be applied on the other
arm by following your finger all the way
up and then connecting with your thumb
and then you have the desired result